what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I'll be
delving into the latest events in the
black clovers story including the elves
tragic battle against Vanek ah the fate
of the Hart Kingdom Queen Laura Pacheco
and the epic showdown between full-power
Dante and the full power Yami so much
action so much drama so let's get into
it
if you enjoyed the black lover content
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know it really does help and
if you're new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video where you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications YouTube's recommendation
system can be very weird and a lot of
the time you're gonna get a bunch of
mainstream corporate recommendations
that you have nothing to do with if you
want to make sure that you're actually
notified when we upload a video please
go through the trouble of clicking the
Bell and selecting the option that says
all it is the only way to make sure that
you will be notified finally this video
will of course contain black holder
manga spoilers we're talking about the
very latest developments in the story so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now if you guys saw my
previous black color video you know what
I said about the ending of the last
chapter I said that even though Noel
managed to rally and strike another blow
against vantika and even though she was
seemingly able to pierce clean through
vana cos torso it was highly unlikely
that this attack would actually hurt
Vanakkam in the past she had already
proven that even such seemingly deadly
attacks don't cause her much damage and
that was confirmed once again in the
latest installment of the story after
the stab occurs Meggie Kula complements
Noel on her spirit but the demon that
confirms that such attacks can't really
harm her but Noel is not done yet she
then launches a sudden point-blank sea
dragons roar attack right at vantika
valve Anika is still impaled upon oil
spear however even with this vanakkam
manages to counter with her blood magic
and in the end the attack is ineffective
to be fair we do see that Veronica /
McGee Kula is spitting up some blood
her mouth but other than that we don't
see any major long-term damage if any of
Noelle's attacks led to serious injuries
vannacutt does not appear to be hindered
by them in any meaningful way at least
not for now as Noel kneels down before
her grimoire her magic giving out and
her body covered with black demon
residue Vanek appalls uh ah da da da
Vanek ah and McGee Kula then asked Noel
what her name is
and a defiant Noel proudly proclaims
that she is Noel Sylva a member of one
of the royal families of the Cobra
Kingdom and a proud black bull magic
knight at this point
Danika once again brings out her
trademark yonder a smile and she tells
McGee Kula that they should stop trying
to kill Noel McGee Kula is surprised but
Monica insists saying that they should
take Laura chika back with them to the
Spade Kingdom while allowing Noel to
live after seeing Noel in her current
state banika finally remembered Noelle's
mother
ah ca silva vantika recalls that she had
fought ah si a in the past and she says
that the fight was a lot of fun now the
various different translations are all
over the place when it comes to this
part of the chapter but it seems that
vantika had taken osseous children or
one of her children as a hostage at some
point in the past some translations are
suggesting that the one who was taken
hostage might have been no Zell but I'm
not sure if this hostage situation
involved just one of her children
multiple children or whether it's
somehow involved Noel as well no L
wouldn't have been born at the time of
the fight so the only way that Noel
could have been held hostage is if
Monica placed some sort of curse on Noel
while she was still inside her mother's
womb but regardless of what exactly
happened back then ah ca silva became
much stronger as a result of this whole
hostage situation this desperate
situation motivated her to surpass her
limits and become much stronger than she
had been before
since Vatika loves a good fight she had
a lot of fun fighting against
the powered-up hace a and so because of
this vantika has decided to take
Noelle's close friend Laura Pacheco as a
hostage and she's doing this in order to
motivate Noel to get stronger just like
her mother did so that sometime in the
future of Anika can have a fun fight
against the powered-up Noel the fact
that vantika thinks this way is a major
clue about her personality she came here
to kill Laura chica and if her goal was
to win this war in the name of the Spade
Kingdom than just killing all her
enemies right now would make the most
sense however her first priority clearly
isn't to win the war her first priority
is to have fun by fighting strong
opponents and so she is willing to let
Noel live just so she could become
stronger and then give Anika a fun fight
sometime in the future even though this
is clearly a risk since if Noel one day
becomes stronger than Manik avantika
could be killed
Veronica is willing to take that risk in
the name of having fun man Vanek I is
like an evil female Goku she just loves
a good fight against a strong opponent
so much that she is willing to put her
own higher goals at risk and as all of
this is happening and as Noel is
experiencing a moment of utter
desperation a new spell begins to burn
itself onto the pages of her grimoire
but what will this new spell be many are
speculating that the new spell will be
Undine herself
many believe that Noel is about to
inherit the water spirit Ondine from
Laura chika but is that true
Laura Pacheco is not dead or anything so
Ken on Dean just choose to team up with
Noel instead or is this a different
spell that Noel has just unlocked after
her a little face to face with Noel
vantika decides that she no longer has
any business inside the hard kingdom and
so she leaves and takes load of a chica
with her but before she leaves
Vanek assess that all of her dark
disciples that had accompanied her into
the heart kingdom are no longer
necessary
she then activates a particular curse
magic spell and this spell causes each
and every one of her dark disciples to
explore
suddenly the demon magic inside all of
her disciples across the heart kingdom
detonates and as vanakkam makes her exit
five massive explosions occur
simultaneously across the heart kingdom
at this point we can't be sure just how
much damage these explosions actually
did but if we can trust the visuals of
the blasts then it is definitely
possible that these explosions have just
killed a whole bunch of innocent
civilians of the heart kingdom and
perhaps they even killed some important
mages from the heart and clover kingdoms
before she left the heart kingdom
vannacutt old noelle that she can
survive the explosion and she also told
her to go get stronger so they can fight
again in the future this exchange
implies that these explosions are indeed
survivable but if we can trust the
visuals of the explosions all of the
blasts certainly look like they are
extremely powerful and wide-ranging
unless it turns out that these
explosions are not quite as strong as
they appear I would be shocked if at
least some people weren't killed as a
result of these blasts at any rate
Vanegas five dark disciples look like
they have been annihilated and this all
happened just because manica casually
decided to make it happen after she
captured Laura Pacheco she was no longer
interested in anything else inside the
heart kingdom and she no longer had any
use for her disciples this tells us a
lot about vantika as a person and about
how much she values anyone who is weaker
than her in some ways vantika is the
ultimate simp slayer and she is even
willing to destroy her own simps as we
see the images of destruction all over
to Hart Kingdom the chapter abruptly
switches focus back to the epic battle
between Yami and Dante man I've been
waiting to see what's going on in that
battle for so long and I am definitely
glad that we got to see another glimpse
of it although it was a brief one
hopefully we will get more in the next
chapter from the looks of it Yami has
been attacking Dante and effectively
landing shots on him over and over again
but Dante has just been using that
grotesque flesh regeneration magic to
heal himself interestingly enough even
Dante says that this magic that he has
been using is on
tightly but he admits that he has no
choice but to keep using it because Yami
is just that strong those are definitely
words of high praise from Dante and to
me this really emphasizes the fact that
Yami is on a whole other level from the
other clover mages that we have been
seeing in action so far including of
course William you don't hasta Noel and
so on Yami isn't a whole other League
and he is able to actually offer a real
challenge to Dante as a result of Yami's
impressive strength dante decides to
show Yami the full extent of his demon
power dante is about to use all of the
demonic power that he is capable of
using meaning that he is about to fight
at his absolute strongest Yami responds
by saying that he is about to show Dante
the true power of an ordinary human and
that is how this action-packed chapter
ends both of these epic warriors are
about to get serious they're about to
reveal their final forms and it is going
to be a legendary judging by what we've
seen so far from the dark triad we have
to assume that Dante at full power is
going to be the strongest villain we
have encountered in black colors so far
however we can't count Yami out either
even though as a quote-unquote ordinary
human he is definitely the underdog in
this battle we cannot underestimate
Yami's dark magic which is incredibly
rare and unique we cannot underestimate
his ability to constantly surpass his
limits and we certainly can't
underestimate Yami's allies I mean just
think about it for years Yami has been
recruiting outcasts from all over the
clover kingdom mages with unique
personalities and even more unique
magical abilities personally I don't
think that Yami will be able to defeat
full power Dante all on his own but
that's the beauty of the black bulls
Yami doesn't have to fight on his own if
Yami is able to make effective use of
his black bull allies then you never
know combining different types of unique
magic in strategic ways is such a major
part of black clover battles and I could
definitely see something like that
happening
in order for the black bulls to defeat
Dante but let me know what you guys
think did Noel just inherit the water
spirit on Dean from Laura Oh chica or
did she just unlock some other magic
spell also how strong is full power
Dante going to be and does Yami stand a
chance against him please don't be shy
hit me up with your thoughts down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more videos like it
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you're new to
anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed make this the day that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar I want to give a big
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible a very special thank you to a
friend a a disciple of Lord Twigg o
himself and I can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah alone Adam the world stealers
acquired respect pot a heffa Jonathan
King deci d Brandon herbalist Papa Smurf
the school bus King riser Emperor otaku
Ritchie Martinez and Thomas Jones and of
course another big thank you to all of
our pro hero to your patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King zelgius Anatole
Cassatt Sookie on hell cruise cricket XP
Joe Stanton very Gucci Alecia ahktar
Jessica Calif on he no come in water
Bonnie parks Zoda are 12 Roth we need a
hora Emperor cynical Kraken full cast 77
and deadly Saint if you enjoy our videos
then you feel that they provide value
for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]